how's the gum raise my name is Peter Pat
we got some awesome chance to play the
evil within a bit early so let's check
it out that looks great let's check out
oh yeah this is where I was too afraid
to go let's check this out oh god he's
so fat oh god he's so fat so very fat
you're a fat fat all right then come
here come here big boy
No No Oh God how many how many does it
need that said the magical number I
don't trust fat [ __ ] all right where
should we go is there something here
maybe I want my next blow oh here we go
cool all right oh god that sounds
seriously don't hush me baby I don't
like this doctors here the doctor of God
no who's the doctor
what that
why do they talk anymore how do we get
inside I'm not sure if I want to get
inside Oh God not this music again
hello all right let's go in here this
will be fantastic
I'm sure are you scared I'm next
Oh God frickin men you keep scaring me
man I want to make sure I'm prepared for
this got it
all right shot shits shout a time girl
Hawaii no tearing what are they doing
finance moves man expose the flesh is
that it I don't understand what do you
want from me I'm just a little boy all
right here we go
oh god what is that oh god what is that
God what is that aah what are they doing
in doctor is here what are we gonna do
with a doctor hello
shush don't you fret Hey look that dr.
Franken don't velarium it's me good
doctor is here so he's dead hilarious
let's this original dolphin great
brother you have there
oh I wanna fine how nice we suppose
everything ah
Hey what are you doing
I put that down sir sir sorry would you
kindly all right
oh he means business I have a bottle get
away from me maybe you'll listen to this
mrs. shotty whoa ha ha amazing oh god
[ __ ] I shouldn't have done that
what
oh come on that's disgusting
looks like Hawaii
I must be going
really your bra I just shot your brother
to ten pieces on dr. Valerio I guess
Valerio wasn't very valid I tried okay I
try and shut up cousin bee ruvik it
looks really good really good
well it's been great sightseeing with
you mate but I think we we better go and
if you know what I'm saying let's get
out of it
that came from outside let's find that
lastly let's find her and make her is
that bottle stuck in my face I don't
think that's supposed to happen that's
the great waited I think think you might
have a drinking problem there sir oh not
okay not okay
shoot our shooter ah saw dunnock victim
oh my god oh oh what is this what is
going on you don't look too good mine
you can reminds me of the guy from that
other game yep oh hi Bert what is this
what is they hello Oh
sunflower it's so pretty oh god it's
like that guy again [ __ ] that guy
alright oh what oh oh gotta get all the
blood go blood go oh what are you doing
with that be that good don't you're
lucky you don't get away with this [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh my god creepy forest just
what I was hoping for
oh my blood girl got a lot of my blood
go [ __ ] let me punch you that's how it
yeah best game ever
that's how we do it
Oh what you were adding blood goo from
me what oh my god alright let's head
over here I don't trust you either
stupid box I hate boxes what was that
what was that
I'm sure there's nothing let's keep
going
Oh God oh Jesus
biggest bird I've seen in my laughs wait
I've seen that house somewhere where in
a magazine maybe I've never been here
before but it's about to get bloody you
know what I'm going with a gun I don't
trust anything oh god it's a door
opening the doors are opening nice knife
you I wish I could there we go
you never know when you might need it
okay
oh bloody go Elmo's missed you mate
thank you
whoa that's a lot of blood kumain hello
there's gonna be bad breasts
what are they pay hello stop damn it
what what the fudge cake
okay there's three of them oh no no no
would we have to follow the Pabst bro
one of the pipes goes into dis I don't
trust you
oh [ __ ] don't break it oh don't oh god
damn it oh god damn it oh that's fine
good thing at oh [ __ ]
bloody goo thank you slaves kind of cozy
I like it pretty house nice paintings
nice furniture and nice spiderwebs love
it it's a nice expense why this pipes
goes in here I can't see
Oh God alright let's just let's just
check in here for oh god as a trap it's
a BAM trap okay we got this brush
no problem purchase
this is the Kachin you are not dead I
don't trust you [ __ ]
dinner is served everyone fresh meat
all be delicious I promise you more
watch I tell you to get off my turf okay
really punching barrels like nobody's
business
Jesus I love it it's M oh here's the
Kachin cool all right you know what
let's what what do we have here
breakfast I suppose oh god no I do not
want it
what chick number 58 Tess 92 a electrode
placement m33
pain regions ineffective Oh
did I do that right I just something
Mosher is this
research that by the register I am most
impressed why are you back
paint give you permission oh come now
we're both men of science men of science
are dedicated to the pursuit of
knowledge you can show me your
experiments I can show you things you
wouldn't like them you'd think they're
gross in science one must do any number
of things a lay person may find it
disgusting I've done many things others
would consider distasteful you think I'm
some kind of a monster you concern
yourself so much with your appearance
but that mind of yours that's all that
matters
they seem [ __ ] crazy I want to play
with this again this is like my favorite
toy in the world it's the brain spike
toy of Justin alright why did it don't
worry what what did hell effect it on no
no no no no no
no no no thank you no thank you
what did I just do what and a loom
minion a look nanny right you calm down
everyone just calm all right I forgot
about that little cow
all right that's it's just a flesh wound
we're fine all right that took care of
that
oh [ __ ] back off - all right all right
all right I'm gonna punch you I'm gonna
punch you I'm gonna punch you learn no
I'm gonna all right you know what about
it we're easy oh damn
Oh your batch oh my god
I swear to God this [ __ ] game
oh so maybe we triggered one of the
locks yeah we did
cool all right does more to Gus cool
that looks like the same red liquid
uh-huh maybe what's in here did we go in
here
this looks great hello we can't go
what's making all that noise what's with
all the ruckus up stays I will not have
it
none of it what how dare you door you
offend me
I'm gonna write a tumblr post about you
let me go [ __ ] that door great paintings
great taste about low words safe dial
this old safe Dell is marked with the
number zero through nine interesting
well you know that's what they did for
fun back in the day I didn't have the
Internet
all right so it's oh wow he did not
liked it that's that's the weird guy
from before isn't it it looks very cool
this game I gotta say up more more i gue
thank you umm oh oh god did that batch
just lack man no let me know she did not
but she did something didn't she whoa
spooks spooks everywhere I believe
what's up what's up what's up Oh God
someone has diarrhea in here I am 99%
certain I've heard this sound before
what
Oh God
yeah there's no point in hiding is it
you look very pretty like your makeup
where is he going
whoa all right well that's one way to do
what a suppose Jesus oh cool oh I'll
take your axe thank you and I'll take
this I'll take this [ __ ] joke on
everything what's here what do we got in
here
nice DJ why are you doing it
Rubik room red I saw her there again
standing at the end of the hallway
long black hair beautiful as ever
streaked with moonlight eyes dark poles
in her porcelain face she wore her
favorite red dress like a crimson sunset
like a streak of blood in the waning
light Laura of course you wouldn't be
you couldn't be dead what do you think
chair actually [ __ ] man I don't know
what else to say
I do agree it's pretty furniture at
least
oh hello mr. go beautiful that's a lot
of places to loot in this game I'm ok
with that
give me all the loot large syringe hello
thank you Oh take this bottle what was
it blood inside her old sign oh god oh
god oh god
ok alright oh nice No do not come near
me don't touch me You Know Who I am
that's the way I guess I'm Lisa listens
I hate more they don't listen now he's
[ __ ] dead we don't need to waste our
matches on that [ __ ] oh what's this ah
thank you
oh alright we're going that we were four
Oh God
hello oh Jesus
what is going on here
nice little hallway I guess what is
going on oh come on no no no no no what
what Oh
minecraft oh my god
the circus Jesus alright the best way
I'm sorry but I gotta end it there but
if you enjoyed watching please go ahead
and leave a like it helps me out a lot
and it makes you had total bro in the
home I don't know an emo damn that was
good stay awesome bros mah